the wealth of characters you have to
develop on a weekly basis that output is
it's astronomical dude yeah it's been a
little more intense lately because we've
been going on the road we just did three
kill Tony's on the road and we come up
with new characters every episode so we
did one on Monday we did three on
between Wednesday Friday and Saturday
and then we just did another one last
night so we had to do five like new
characters or we'll bring back
characters to kind of like spaced out
because you know if character is
successful we'll bring it back and like
I'm cool honing it and and keep trying
to make it better and tighter stuff like
that no we need to do five within seven
or eight days and that was that a lot
how organized is that aspect cuz like
you said controlled chaos and that's why
I'm such a fan of you is because you are
able to pull off what seemingly is
absurd but it's very well calculated
it's like you're like you said the
second city background like everything
is honed in and purposeful but I love
when people are able to walk that line
in comedy between like what but it's so
well-executed that it's palatable you
know yeah well I learned that if you
kind of set the parameters for yourself
with jokes or a show or whatever and you
set your own guidelines then you have
the full room to play because you know
where the boundaries are you know how
far you can push things because you have
like a template basically so for the
characters for kill Tony we have like
this master list where we'll have like
brainstorm sessions where we're like we
could do this is like we start writing
just like everything that we think they
could be fun or cool to commit to
basically for you know a 90 minute
episode and sometimes you know sometimes
the characters never come back because
they're either really hard to improvise
within or they're not
three dimensional enough there to like
one dimensional if that makes sense so
like we just did these uh like nurse
characters like a couple weeks ago and
maybe if we took another crack at them
but like try improvising just as a nurse
for 90 minutes it's like you know you
you throw out your medical terms and
stuff like that but like after that it's
like yeah but what's your point of view
as the nurse and sometimes on the format
of show like kill Tony like sometimes
you can't get to the point of view and
if you don't get to your point of view
then you can't play you know what I mean
like in an improv scene that's why
there's rules like that they teach you
improv schools like set up the who what
where when the why like set those up
then you can play because if you don't
set those up then you're just kind of
floating around and this black void of
space we were like I don't really know
this information yet and it hasn't been
established so I can't really hit the
ground running I can tell that stuff is
set so that's what will happen sometimes
with the characters that we don't bring
back is we never found the point of view
for those characters and we have to read
like analyze and try to figure that out
if that makes sense so are you trying to
find those answers before the show is
this all in the motion so we try to find
it before the show but sometimes it's
like whenever we're doing like five
characters and you know seven or eight
days you sometimes find at middle is
shown then you're like that's that's
what this characters thing is so
sometimes before the show ideally you'd
like to have a strong point of view with
the characters but sometimes you may not
know it you're just like I just think
this is a like inherently as something
to my gut is like there's something
funny about this character or this
profession or whatever and then you find
it kind of as you go how do you find the
point of view like you said some of you
find before the show what is your
process for finding that that's kind of
a trial and error kind of thing like you
also it depends heavily on what the
audience is responding to as well or
what the guests on the show are or the
or you know host ghost whatever if
they're like we found this this one
character where I didn't find this angle
till towards the end of the episode
where and I'll bring this character back
eventually because it did really well
but I was Darth Vader and like I was
playing it pretty straightforward as
Darth Vader and later on the show I was
literally in hot and tired and my
posture changed to eventually where I my
head is down and they're like you okay
over there I'm like I'm not doing well
right now what's wrong Vader like you
know and then like it got a big response
from the audience and I'm like we
started like going back and forth and we
came up with like the angle that is
really funny like for a take on Darth
Vader he's really sad so is like sad
Vader yeah they kept going back like
later in the episode they're like is
everything okay over there and I just be
super depressing and low every time they
come back to me and like I haven't seen
my son in years just stupid but you find
stuff like that sometimes it takes a
while
like I said trial and error to kind of
figure out like what's what would be
funny about that and then becomes the
game yeah then that becomes the game and
you just tight night-night and so in
stand-up if you're doing a lot of improv
onstage are you recording these sets and
reviewing them I audio record all my
sets so if I am riffing something on
stage that I liked then I'll go back and
listen to it and I'll I definitely will
transcribe stuff and I'll write all the
way out okay yeah yeah you you're that
that's the work behind it that's the
work that's the that's like where you
know it's fun to go up onstage this the
work to go back and listen to sets that
you don't really want to listen to yes
there yeah they're they're never really
as bad as you think they are when you
listen back they're never really is good
listening back either yeah but then you
sometimes you think the bombs are the
worst of the hardest to listen to
because when you kill you're like well
of course let me do my victory lap and
listen
when it's when it doesn't go well those
are the ones you gotta listen to because
you may just find a spark in there
sometimes sometimes it depends I'm all
about like keeping a healthy and
positive mindset and it if it's uh you
know if it's if you know it's gonna be
really negatively impact like your
mental psyche then like I usually like I
know what I did wrong
I can't listen this this is like you
know but so I used to force myself I you
still hike like early on is look I mean
I use like nine tails like know like I
know what I did wrong there I I know
what like you learn you learn your
lessons a little bit quicker true as you
go on yeah you've made those mistakes
sometimes you you're like I've already
made that mistake why am i doing that
mm-hmm but it takes that review process
to then create the awareness yeah of
like oh I made this mistake okay or in
the middle of a show you may or I made
that mistake again but I know I can
recover based on that awareness now yeah
I think as someone who put that the
reviewing perspective because it's it's
so hard to have the discipline to do it
but then I heard like Joe Rogan and you
be like he's like like you listen to all
your sets he's like do your homework
like what do you what do you mean yes I
listen to my sets do your homework it's
part of the work and he just said it
just so flatly of like no this is part
of being a comedian do you want to be a
comedian do you want to be good or what
level do you want to be a comedian at
yeah so even someone at his level is
like you gotta got to do your homework
so that's what I like people to
appreciate in this podcast is just the
work and the labor that goes in to oh
they're just talking for an hour it's
like you didn't see the 20 hours of
failure behind that hour
I breath